part two of my english teacher trying to
fail me even though i had a high grade
in her class in high school those of you
that didn't see part one i went on a
trip to florida in high school and i had
to miss a week of school my mom just
didn't really want to deal with the
hassle of telling the school we were
going on vacation so she just told the
school i was sick i come back from
florida i didn't know she told them that
i'm in class and i'm showing people pics
of my vacation from florida i got to
swim with dolphins of course i'm going
to show people that since this teacher
didn't like me anyway she ends up going
to the principal and it becomes this
huge thing they want to give me a zero
for everything i missed that week even
though the stuff that i made up i got an
a on after like a million meetings with
the principal they ended up giving us
our way i had a big enough fuss that
they just honestly were tired of it
teacher told me that you will never
succeed in college like for part three